interdite lors de sa sortie la pièce
toile d'araignée met en scène une
famille argentine durant les années 70
écrite en pleine dictature son auteur
eduardo peuple ce qui est un des
porteurs du théâtre politique en théâtre
volontairement provocateur cette pièce
est une pièce d'engagement une pièce de
résistance
voilà qui met en scène une famille
argent et tim pris dans une sphère de
renfermement sur elle même
avec comme toile de fond
le football qui est très présent là bas
on en argentine autre thème abordé les
jeux de hasard qui sont également très
présents à cette époque cette adaptation
qui sera jouée à la ferme de bel ébat
montre notamment comment une famille
perd ses valeurs
une pièce jouée en français et en
espagnol sur scène cinq comédiens dont
un argentin franco qu'abriel joue le
rôle d'un policier
c'est un sujet hyper fort pour les
sachants temps et c'est pas quelque
chose qui s'est passé il ya énormément
du temps c'est assez récent dans
l'histoire dans la mémoire du peuple aux
arches en temps c'est quand même très
intéressant de dépenser l'auteur comment
il a rédigé la pièce et comment avec son
parcours de psychanalystes rend ma tour
sa militance politique a pu conduire
cette pièce toile d'araignée s'adresse à
un public averti
plusieurs tableaux montrent les
violences commises pendant cette période
exemple cette scène où deux policiers
rentrent dans la maison
on a appelé ça les disparitions de
personnes le régime avait décidé de
faire non pas d'emprisonner de fusiller
les gens mais de les faire disparaître
donc on a serré et 70% des des
disparitions se faisait à domicile c'est
à dire qu'il y avait des intrusions
on a appelé ça des escadrons de la mort
deux représentations seront données les
25 et 26 février
la deuxième sera suivie d'un débat avec
le groupe local de saint quentin en
yvelines d'amnesty international